ah from whoever called registration here  to be poisoning by chemical agents the  Syrians are paying millions to build up  their biological Arsenal and the day you  signed up I've been watching you from  far making sure you're okay  is there why you brought me here err  it's your father  I will do whatever is needed to help you  this woman has our best lead in years do  you have a plan they need her all I have  to do is to get her to need me before  these biological weapons fall into the  wrong hands  things are moving fast is she gonna take  the bait  what if she doesn't I might be able to  help you guys the harbor doctor or is  called a spider in the web of people out  there do anything to stop me from  exposing the truth you'd be lying to us  you cannot stay where do you know what  my orders are this thing runs deep  I'm the one who pushed you  ninety-one  I'm done  you